et puis en biélorussie les
manifestations contre la réélection
controversée du président alexandre
loukachenko se poursuivre hier des
dizaines de milliers de biélorusses ont
défilé dans les rues de la capitale
minsk pour un troisième week-end
consécutif est les forces de l'ordre ont
tenté sans succès d'empêcher les
manifestants de se rejoindre
ml non utilisés a dit gaz lacrymogènes
des balles en caoutchouc comme cela
avait été le cas alors du week-end
précédent
et justement écouter le point de vue de
bruno 12 qui secoue historien est maître
de conférences à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
nous sommes toujours en train d'analyser
le rapport de forces est à dire qui
réussit à mobiliser le plus fortement
ses partisans bon il est clair que de
toute façon tôt ou tard il va bien
falloir négocier alors la question c'est
qui négociera avec ti alors là le point
de vue du président loukachenko
c'est que on doit discuter une nouvelle
constitution et aboutir à un référendum
sur la constitution alors que les
manifestants veulent une nouvelle
élection présidentielle est donc entre
les deux évidemment apparemment il n'ya
pas de convergence possible mais tôt ou
tard on donnera bien arriver à un
compromis sur quel type de vote aura
lieu en biélorussie référendum ou une
élection présidentielle